مشاهد قاسيه لا يحتملها عقل ولا قلب ظهرت
في حضانه جارد ريف اللبنانيه وذلك لمربيات
يعنفن اطفالا لم يتجاوزوا عمر الورود
للاسف بالقسوه والاض تمارس هذه المربيات
الساديه لا يمكن وصفها تجاه اطفال تركوا
امان بين ايديهم حيث اعتقد ذوهم انهم
سيكونون بخير طبعا صوره تعنيف القاسيه
مشاهدينا التي نراها الان حركت المشاعر
ليس فقط في لبنان ولكن في العالم العربي
ايضا ايضا حركت الجهات الرسميه لاتخاذ
اللازم واعلنت وزاره الصحه اللبنانيه
تحديث القوانين الخاصه بالحضانات فضلا عن
تركيب كاميرات ايضا بكل حضانه وفي الوقت
الذي نعرض فيه هذه القصه حكايه المربيات
القاسيات مستمره ولكن امام القضاء لعله
ينصف اطفال الحضانه المعنفين
احكي لنا اكثر يعني احنا سمعنا بانه طفله
كان موجود بالفيديو من الاطفال اللي كانوا
عم يبكوا
ما بعرف اذا للاسف تعرض لمثل هذا التعنيف
ام لا احكيلنا القصه من وجهه نظرك صراحه
بعدنا صدمه
اخلاقيه صدمه نفسيه
ما بقى نقدر نتحمل ما بقى نعرف منين ما
بنعرف نقوم من ورا الشيء اللي صار نحن أنا
مبارح من وقت خطبني على الجرجريه متلو
يعني الصبح بتلاقي بحضرتك اللي اعطتني
الفيديوهات واجتمعنا بالبيت مثل كل
عارفيني يعني خبر وصرنا نتوسع بالموضوع
توصلنا اخذنا
عملنا شو اسمه الدعوه وهيك وصلنا لهون هلا
انا ابني مش موجود بالفيديو اللي محطوط
على السوشيال ميديا بس انه ابني موجود مع
الولاد يعني اكيد هو يعني اكيد اكيد بما
انه موجود يعني هو مثله متلون يعني انا
الصراحه في نقطه بعد كل اللي حكيناه يعني
الرقابه من وزاره الصحه هن عم يعملوا
تفتيش قالوا عم يعمل ورد وتفتيش من وزاره
الصحه على الجرجريه اللي ابني فيها
طيب ليش عم يعطوا خبر
للجرجريه انه نحن جايين نفتش عندكم صح
وهذه بعتقد انا هيدي نقطه اساسيه لانه
وزاره الصحه بس بدها تروح تراقبه تروح
بشكل طبيات بتعمل طبيات على الجارديريه
تشوف شو عم بصير جوا مش تخبرن قبل الجمعه
وتقول انا رايح اعمل طبيه عليكم حضروا
حالكم ردوا اموركم
على السوشيال ميديا في موظف في في موظف في
تشتغل بالجار وعطيتنا الفيديوهات طلعت من
هلا اعطيتنا
الفيديوهات وصرنا نحن
على الوضع الاهل اكيد اكيد يعني
ما بعرف هلا شو غايتها شو شو هي الاسباب
اللي عندك نحن بهمنا الموضوع وصلونا
الفيديوهات نحن حكيت مع الاهلي والاهلي
صرنا نتصرف